[Music]
for people living with type 1 diabetes
tight glucose levels are really
important because they dramatically
reduce the risk of complications
affecting the eyes the nerves and the
kidneys
the artificial pancreas offers great
promise for patients with diabetes
but researchers are still in the process
of gathering evidence through trials
researchers like helen murphy at the
university of east anglia
so the importance of tight glucose
levels is well established but actually
the realities of how to achieve it are
really quite challenging so for those of
us with a normal functioning pancreas
our bodies are making insulin
and adjusting that insulin really every
five to ten minutes
whereas for people with diabetes they're
having to inject insulin
they might do that three or five times a
day
and but it's really difficult to mimic
what the normal functioning pancreas
does
so really people living with type 1
diabetes are almost need to be expert
nutritionists
they need to understand exactly how much
carbohydrates in their food
and then they need to be mathematical
geniuses to match the insulin
dose very precisely to the amount of
carbohydrates that they eat
so the real difference between the
conventional
insulin delivery that's delivered by
injections or by an insulin pump
compared to the artificial pancreas is
that the artificial pancreas is able to
deliver small amounts of insulin
little and often so it's mimicking a
normal functioning pancreas in that way
if you like
because it's adjusting insulin every 10
to 12 minutes including during the
overnight when people are asleep
so the artificial pancreas has got three
components a continuous glucose monitor
an insulin pump and a mathematical
algorithm that links the insulin pump
delivery to the real-time glucose levels
over the last decade the advancing
continuous glucose monitoring has meant
that we've been able to start some high
quality research studies
into the artificial pancreas across a
whole range of different patient groups
so the early studies for the artificial
pancreas have been conducted
in children as young as one and right up
to adults in the age of 80.
now the group that i work with in
particular are pregnant women
so we've been really delighted to be
able to work together
with bioengineers and bring the latest
artificial pancreas developments
to this important patient population
helen has been running a trial of a
newly developed closed-loop artificial
pancreas system at her local hospital
with pregnant women with diabetes the
trial is ongoing
but she spoke to one of the trial
participants specialist midwife nina
willa to hear how it had affected her
glucose control
during her pregnancy well in my previous
pregnancy i was using
a combination of finger pricking and
freestyle libre
and so for this having the alarm
function just on the dexcom alone
is quite life-changing because i don't
have to worry so much about having
significant high pose
but also when my blood sugars rise
um even if i had no awareness of it if i
was sleeping through it
then i wake up always on a perfect blood
sugar level no matter what happens
the um the algorithm just kicks in and
takes care of it
and also i feel more in tune with what's
going on with my body
and more educated and i think that's
been one of the real things we've
noticed the feedback that actually just
the importance of waking up
with a blood sugar that's already on
target rather than
having to spend half of your morning
catching up starting the day
right makes such a difference and i feel
like
i spent a lot of my awake hours and the
sleep
hours worrying about my diabetes when i
wasn't pregnant but then again when
you're pregnant you've got to worry
about the baby as well
it's quite a high stress situation
whereas this
i'm still thinking about it and i'm
still informed but i'm somewhat on
autopilot
and it just reduces my stress levels so
much and really that's our hope for all
pregnant women
that they can be a little bit more on
autopilot with their diabetes
and yeah enjoying a healthy pregnancy
and
delivering safe healthy babies where
we're up to
now is we're i think getting the real
world evidence
that the closely bart visual pancreas
can achieve
tighter glucose levels than any of the
compo individual components by
themselves
so we're up to the larger scale what we
call the phase three or the clinical
effectiveness trials
the next phase of course is going to
involve health economics and regulators
and getting these devices approved for
real-world use and by people with
diabetes
so what i think we're going to see over
the next five to 10 years
will be a wider variety of different
sorts of closed loop artificial pancreas
systems
hopefully we will see pumps that a whole
range of pumps that are
insulin pumps that are compatible with
the artificial pancreas
we'll start to see smaller even more
accurate continuous glucose monitoring
systems and already we see the control
algorithms are
worn on used on a smartphone
people can access the glucose data on a
smart watch
so the devices are becoming less
intrusive more user-friendly
easier to incorporate into normal daily
living
but of course the question everyone
wants to ask is will are these a cure
and you know the honest answer is that
probably they're not don't necessarily
represent a cure they represent
you know fantastic technological
progress
towards a cure we think of it like the
bridge to a cure
so in the meantime the artificial
pancreas is certainly the best
technological solution we have
that's likely to help the largest number
of people achieve the target glucose
levels that they need
to reduce their risk of complications
you